pardonnez moi c'était la mission que
vous appréciez particulièrement où
c'étaient les bachelorette bonne
question
j'aimais bien chez les lionnes émission
jadot mais c'était l'émission vous êtes
sûr oui parce que tu me connais un tout
petit peu et donc du coup j'ai fouillé
un peu ma mémoire
oui et il me semble si je ne m'avance
pas trop oui que vous étiez très proche
de certaines bachelorette des années
dans le morning live donc forcément non
dieu il est une ex et adresse une fois
le bail ces cons là parce que j'ai fini
dans mes affaires
ouais voiliers et j'ai trouvé ceci je
vais me faire demander un gros plan
voilà on peut dire cela colère à un
cyril hanouna
le matin il anime le morning live
l'après midi ils courent retrouver mais
la noix
[Applaudissements]
je me ferais si votre votre amour pour
le l'émission mais ils n'ont rien dit il
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je me suis pas arrêté la couverture pour
ses bières vous ne connaissez un
journaliste d'investigation
j'ai ouvert l'article et je les lui et
on peut lire depuis que cyril hanouna a
croisé le regard mutin de ces pétillants
ils font l ani l'une des plus jolies
vaches leur est il est totalement accro
après un dimanche de folie à écumer les
coins branchés
les amoureux ont attendu quelques jours
pour mieux se connaître vous écumez les
poindron chez vous et attendez je vous
dis non mais c'est pas du tout ce qu'il
a il faut expliquer clairement les
choses j'avais reçu cette jeune fille
dans le morning man la voilà on a été
prendre un verre ensemble
de fil en aiguille on s'est revus est
vraiment en toute amitié marqué la
légende d'une des photos il y avait
inscrit
olivier le bachelor était millionnaire
me tout réfléchi elle préfère cyril et
ses blagues à deux balles
[Applaudissements]
zidane ici la voix oui là où il avoit
oui cyril la voudrait explorer un peu le
dossier il n'y en aurait pas d'autres
par hasard au hasard vous êtes un
amoureux de la télé mais pas que
physique visiblement a alors il y a eu
un autre bail
les masques tombent les masques il ya eu
un autre bail a qu'une autre
bachelorette avec qui j'étais très
proche c'est la même saison mais parce
que j'arrête de sioux parce que non mais
je me dis brera très loin mais les il
avait reçu dans le morning man est elle
aussi donc de fil en aiguille on est
devenus amis
voilà mais rien de grave non et je peux
vous dire ça allez on y va
ces bouts de matches lors d'accord
compris cyril oui mais oui est-ce que
c'est elle ok je veux dire quelque chose
et un truc moi que je kiffe grave chez
les filles c'est qu'elle mange une
merguez imagine que c'est la merguez de
l'homme de ta vie oui marie valérie
grotte ça allait regagner la jambe à
papa papa qui louera par ba ba ba ba
[Musique]
sociale qui décide ici la voix très
choqué mais très ajouté si la voix qui
est très choqué il n'y a pas de désir
mais là-bas y avait un mois
c'est même moi je suis choqué par cette
personne mais vous couchez avec tout les
invités c'est pas du tout arrêter c'est
très déplacé du show et magloire les ai
passé quelques non matches ça on est
assez stupide pour quoi vous n'avez pas
disent ils ont son personal away merci
en tout cas visiblement vous avez
apprécié les années 2000 mais s'il vous
plaît on est invité il ya déjà bien de
voix qui est humain il ya des gens qui
nous regardent où tessa l'avoir jetée
pour le show bien c'est raté à 2000
c'est que demi une riposte cheryl il y
aurait peut-être peut-être d'autres
dossiers
ce n'est pas tout
[Applaudissements]
les années 2000 où les allées rattrapage
alors qu'à utile de te retourner inutile
c'est toi qui dois parler un allait
assumer un autre dossier
oui mais où dans les bâches lorette
débrouille toi non y aller oui non je
vois là j'avoue j'ai eu quelques
aventures avec les bachelor et 3 voilà
trois mois mais trois saisons quand même
donc à un moment
[Applaudissements]
c'est le début le strike pas du tout et
je vous dirai tout à votre honneur série
vous savez recevoir ou donner je vais
vous dire pas du tout c'était voilà
c'est le hasard des choses qui étaient
des jeunes filles très sympathique qui
voit là on avance on s'est lié d'amitié
et voilà aujourd'hui j'espère qu'elles
vont très bien voilà merci à elle en
tout cas
en fait elles ont préféré vous un
milliardaire elle était juste médium en
fait ouais ouais je voyais jouer cinq
mètres du but fait on comprend pas ce
que vous dites moi je me comprends merci
et bon ben là c'est tout la voix ya plus
rien sur moi et un autre à savoir sur
l'accord
je suis fou de lui j'aimerais qu'il soit
là tous les empires c'est un truc de fou